hi everyone it's Jerry I have a brief
attacking game to share with you this
was played at the 2019 St Louis rapid in
Blitz a Blitz game here between Fabiano
Carana on the white end and ding
lurin those of you who are Carol con
players will almost certainly enjoy this
one it's not every day you get to see
the kocan win in only 26
moves now with the setup
dingin goes with in this one he takes
what's normally a slower more positional
opening and turns it into an attacking
weapon so really whichever side of the
board you find yourself on I think this
is an important game to be familiar with
we work with an exchange carolan
standard moves now Bishop D3 Knight C6
and C3 to defend the pawn and secure the
bishop one quick note to help make this
game more memorable for you each side
takes at least one step to prevent the
active deployment of the enemy Queen
Bishop or the bad Bishops in this case
we see this on move five with Queen
C7 no Bishop F4 and also
H3 no Bishop
G4 eventually of course playing it
straight away not a good idea but this
move once it's in Bishop G4 becomes an
idea now for right now when I see H3 I
view it as a
preventor defending a square and also
producing a flight Square for White Once
castled as play develops as Black's
setup is in place I start to see H3 in a
different way in a negative way for
white we continue with Knight
F6 Knight A3 looking to maybe Converge
on C7 a quick Knight B5 Bishop
F4 this IDE is ruled out altoe with
A6 Knight C2 and G6 at first glance you
may say Black's preparing to feing ketto
this is not the primary function behind
G6 instead it is to develop the bad
Bishop in general black is welcome to
this exchange not the move played in the
game black is welcome to this because of
the great grip now over the E4 Square
this Knight is really well supported on
e4 also you could view it this half
openen G file is now that much more
appealing for black with the pawn now on
H3 G3 is that much more weakened a
knight on e4 is not easily kicked either
one day if you ever play F3 the Knight
has a jump into
G3 Cara's play in this one is to duck
the bad for good Bishop
Exchange in comes E6 proceed with
caution playing a move like
this the bishop doesn't have any Retreat
squares now so before you play this move
you have to ask yourself am I going to
be trapped if G4 you're not but still
something to question the bishop has the
E4 square or the capture
available from here castles and now H5
so this is setting up possibly a fishing
pole idea it is available possible
knight jump into
G4 if captured black has the H file to
work with possibly a mate on
H2 in addition to a fishing pole idea
you could also say that black is now one
step closer to engaging with this H3
Pawn just to tempy away one two G5
G4 this is now a possible hook for an
attack from here Knight E1 Bishop D6 a
very flexible post for the dark Square
Bishop noing ketto kind of biting on a
rock from
G7 stares at both sides of the board
from D6 it fights over these two squares
that the pawn
supports Knight
D3 Knight E4 brings us to the halfway
point of the game both of these Knights
are focused on E5 now that the Knight is
on e4 if a knight hops in to this Square
maybe it's going to be kicked straight
away with
F6 Bishop
E3 no same sides castles in this game
queenside castles on board so this is
really once queenside castles is in this
is really where you see this H3 Pawn as
a
liability from here Rook C1 G5 straight
away no supporting move
with F6 he simply gets on with
G5 now what's considered best in this
position is to play C4 to justify this
last move C4 never hits in this game and
this ends up being a
waste so the suggestion C4 this is
considered a
Topline captures on C4 and then after G4
it says hop in the center and allow this
capture allow the G file to open up this
is not at all easy for a human to play
it calls it about even
here what is the direction for white he
takes the
pawn so now it's a race you know whose
attack is going to hit there first this
is already considered a winning position
for
black
F4 Knight G3 Rook F2 and now the Knight
is given a kick back to F3 the Knight
Returns to E4 targeting The Rook Rook F1
and the g Pawn is pinned so we got
Bishop takes H3 and now this is the
focus the G2 Square it's
defended in comes
H4 King H2 and from
here battery on the G file Queen looking
to sweep in here with a check next
knocking out the
bishop G2 is
defended or is it really black can still
take on
G2 and Bishop takes there's two ways to
recapture in the game white takes with
the
bishop how does play continue if
Knight takes
Bishop black can play with Queen G3
check King
H1 and then H3 you see the idea
here there's a really big threat let's
say black moves the Knight that would
seem like the most logical reply to
H3 well the queen gets to go to
G2 and it doesn't matter now which way
the queen is captured let's say the
Knight takes black would get to
recapture say double check and then give
Checkmate that is a that is a beautiful
attacking sequence right
there in this game it is Bishop takes
Bishop which allows Queen G3 check King
H1 Queen takes Bishop black is attacking
for free
black is up upon in
fact Rook F3
played final move of this game I wonder
if you can spot it feel free to pause
the
video okay black doesn't have to go
anywhere with the
queen H3 and white
resigns if the bishop moves it's mate
right away if the bishop doesn't move
it's going to be captured
uh what other options are there Rook
takes Pawn you take the rook and then
take the bishop and say mate and of
course if the queen is captured we would
get that same idea of a double check and
then
mate what did you think of this
one anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comment section below I hope you enjoyed
it and maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care
bye